savez à quel point il est important de
conserver ce que nous faisons ici au
québec et ce qui se fait ailleurs aussi
en cinéma et en télévision
c'est l'une des vocations de la
cinémathèque québécoise et après trois
ans de travaux c'est aujourd'hui que la
nouvelle cinémathèque voit le jour elle
est maintenant moderne dynamique plus
vaste et plus accueillante aussi fondé
en 1963 par un groupe de cinéphiles
passionnés
la cinémathèque québécoise a toujours un
peu souffert d'une méconnaissance du
grand public
34 ans plus tard les choses sont en
train de changer en plus de conserver le
patrimoine cinématographique et
télévisuelle on a dorénavant la ferme
intention de le rendre accessible à tous
les projections publiques par exemple
passe à 20 séances par semaine pour le
cinéma télé dans lesquels on débute qui
a huit séances télévision par semaine la
bibliothèque accueille désormais 45
lecteurs au lieu de 17 18
c'est vraiment une ouverture chez le
tout le projet était fondée sur cette
notion là non seulement les heures
d'ouverture mais toutes les collections
la cinémathèque était pas aussi visible
qu'elles vont l'être maintenant placer
ses installations là cette institution
qui dévoile en fait les trésors qu'elles
abritent se veut un véritable musée du
prochain siècle une salle claude-jutra
complètement rénové pour accueillir tous
les formats de pellicule sans parler des
archives télévisuelles projeté dans la
salle fernand séguin des expositions une
médiathèque toutes équipées au sous sol
et un écran sur la façade extérieure de
l'édifice un projet de 16 millions de
dollars qui voit le jour au coeur de
montréal en créant leur de pépi avec le
trottoir et en deux l'un de transparence
maintenant quand les gens vont circuler
vont voir l'écran géant qui ont tous
temps va diffuser la programmation de la
cinémathèque et on va attirer les gens
l'intérieur écouter en étant quelqu'un
et se jette du vieux on n'est pas tant
sur juste à côté du métro et la rue
saint denis
c'est le cas du quartier latin on avait
tous une faveur pour rentrer les gens
dans le bâtiment et les gars disent
d'abord un lieu de trois étages de haut
avec une agora suspendu des projections
partout on a essayé d'inventer un
nouveau lieu quelque chose qui n'existe
pas montréal c'est à dire un hybride
entre la salle de cinéma l'auditorium et
le hall d'entrée
les gens pourront découvrir le nouveau
look de la cinémathèque québécoise
puisque dès vendredi commence les 15èmes
rendez vous
cinéma québécois et le 9 mars va
reprendre la programmation régulière
et puis le 24 mars histoire de voir ce
qui se fait ailleurs en cinéma le public
pourra surveiller sur cet écran géant
la soirée des oscars marie christine
trottier à montréal